- So welcome, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming
to this special event.
My name is Hwansoo Kim,
and I teach Korean religion and culture
in the Department of Religious Studies.
I also serve as chair of the
council on East Asian Study.
It is my tremendous
honor to host this event
for two prominent scholars of
East Asian history, politics,
and culture.
The central theme of today's
conversation is what is Korea?
Of course, Korea has not
existed in isolation,
and thus, the more specific question is
how has Korea preserved its
political and cultural identity
throughout the 5,000 years
of its tumultuous history?
An identity that it has
shared, and negotiated,
and contested with those of
its neighboring countries,
China, and Japan, and beyond.
Professor Myung Chul
Youn will give two talks.
One today, and the other, this Friday,
to shed some lights on this subject.
And to make our
conversations more relevant
to modern and contemporary
international relations,
Professor Odd Arne Westad
from the Department of
History here at the Yale
is kindly joining us to share reflections
from his most and highly acclaimed book
called "Empire and Righteous Nations,
600 Years of China-Korea Relations,"
which is also translated into Korean.
So these three talks
combined, luckily for us,
will spend the entire 5,000
years of Korean history,
and enlighten us on the distinctive
and common characteristics
of Korean identity
in the regional and global context.
These talks will also eliminate
the precarious conditions
on the Korean Peninsula in the face
of a Beijing centric order,
and the increasing assertiveness of Korea
with this international influence.
So today's event will be
divided into two parts.
Professor Westad will
first speak for 30 minutes
about his book, followed
by Professor Youn.
Professor Youn's presentation
will be translated
by my dear colleague, Professor Juhn Ahn
from the University of Michigan.
Thank you so much.
He's a professor of Korean studies.
So he's joining us,
especially for this purpose.
After the two presentations,
our speakers will have the opportunity
to ask questions of each other,
and we'll then open the
floor for your questions
from the audience.
In the interest of time,
and due to the video
recording of today's event,
I would ask that you write your questions
on the note cards being distributed,
and I'll be reading later
on after collecting them.
Let me briefly introduce our two speakers.
Dr. Myung Chul Youn is a
Professor Emeritus of History
at Dongguk University,
and is currently Professor
of Archeology at Samarkand
State University of Uzbekistan.
His research focuses on the
history of the Korea period
from the first century BC
to the eighth century CE,
as well as East Asian Maritime history.
He's published over 60 books
and numerous journal articles.
He's also poet, an explorer,
and has published 14 books of poetry.
Professor Odd Arne Westad is a scholar
of modern international and global history
with a specialization in
the history of Eastern Asia
from the 18th century on.
He studied at the University of Oslo
before receiving his graduate degree
at the University of North
Carolina in Chapel Hill.
Professor Westad has published 16 books,
many articles, and
received numerous awards.
He taught at the London
School of Economics
and Harvard History, and you
joined Yale three years ago?
- 2019.
- Yeah.
And Yale snatched him
from Harvard. (laughs)
Today's event is supported
by Hong-nam Kim's
Korean Studies Fund.
And special thanks go to
the council staff, Kathy,
and particularly in Jung
Kim, without logistic helps,
I will be deeply exhausted
and sick in bed. (laughs)
So without further ado,
please join me in welcoming
Professor Arne Westad.
(audience applauding)
- So thank you very much, Hwansoo,
for that wonderful introduction.
It's a great honor for me
today to speak together
with Professor Youn.
I want to hear what he has to say.
So I will be relatively
brief in presenting my book.
And for those of you who are at Yale,
you know where to find me, so
you can easily seek me out,
and discuss these things with me.
So this is a book that came
out of a set of lectures,
so-called Reischauer Lectures
that I did at Harvard in 2017.
And the idea is to try to
look at the relationship
between China and Korea over
a long period of time, right?
And in order to get to some
of the essential aspects
of that relationship.
It has been an ever-changing relationship,
as you'll hear me talk about in a minute.
But there are some structural
aspects of it that seem to me
to connect at least the
period when I start up
at the beginning of the
Ming and the Joseon states
are two waters come later.
So it is not without relevance
when we try to understand
today's relationship between
the new Chinese state
calls itself the People's
Republic of China
and the two Korean states.
So history matters,
but not always in the
manner that we assume.
There is no automaticity in this.
But people learn from their history,
at least they try to
learn from their history.
Because there isn't all that much more
that you can learn from,
particularly when you're
dealing with neighbors from.
In Korea's case, very powerful neighbors
to the north, and the
western, and the east as well.
You have to learn.
And Korea has learned
through that long process.
The empires learn as well.
Though they learn differently.
They learn in a different form.
This is where the title
of the book comes from,
empire and righteous nation.
And Professor Youn has the
recently published Korean edition
to which I wrote a new preface.
So by talking about empire,
it wouldn't be that
difficult to understand
who I have in mind when
I speak about empire.
I speak about China in its various forms.
So we are dealing with
several different incarnations
of these states, going
back to the early Ming era.
I wanna talk a little bit
about empire in a minute
in more general terms,
but it's pretty clear what
the title refers to, at least,
in terms of empire.
Now, righteous and nation are
more complicated concepts.
And I spend quite a bit of time
at the beginning of this book
to talk about those concepts.
Now, by referring to
Korea, again, no surprise,
it's Korea referring to
when I use the expression
righteous nation as righteous.
I don't of course mean that
every Korean is righteous
far from it.
That is not based on historical evidence.
I like Koreans, but not that much,
that I would call all of them righteous.
It would also be unfair
too much to live up to.
What I mean is that
concepts of righteousness.
E in Chinese, we in Korean is something
that has played a particular role
in Korean history going far back.
It is an integral part of
the Neo-Confucian revolution
that the early Joseon state
signaled and symbolized.
And it also became a key aspect,
both of trying to understand
how Korean society should work,
but perhaps more importantly
over time at critical junctures
in Korean history, as you
will know better than me,
as a resistance to foreign domination.
So righteousness in this context,
of course, has many meanings.
But part of it is an appeal
to a Korean understanding
of the fundaments of what
it means to be Korean.
The essence of the discussion
that we are going to have today,
which of course has varied
enormously over time, right?
It is not in any way static.
But this concept seems to me
to come up again and again
in various forms.
Now, the concept nation is of course,
also if you go back to
the late 14th century
problematic with regard to Korea.
And I'd like us to spend some
time if we have afterwards,
maybe discussing.
As I was writing this book,
and I actually wrote most
of the book in Beijing
when I was visiting at Peking University.
I started thinking very seriously
about the use of the concept nation,
which of course is a 19th century
European invention, right?
In order to try to
understand Korean history
in an earlier time period,
if you use this concept
within a framework of automaticity,
of course it becomes
centrally anachronistic.
But if you, as Professor
Habush and others, have done
go to the core of the
European romantic concept
of nation in terms of how it is defined.
Then I think it's very
hard to avoid the tool
that Korea very distinctly
in an eastern nation context.
Have some of those
characteristics already coming out
of the beginning or being
formed during the beginning
of the time period that I'm talking about.
And particularly during
the Great East Asian War
in the late 16th century,
as has been noted
by many historians that I build on,
not these Korean historians.
Some of those characteristics
of what it meant to be
in a professed proud way,
a nation in Europe in the 19th century
also seem to be rather strikingly similar.
To some, not all, of the
concepts that Korean identity
builds during that time.
So that's why it's called
"Empire and Righteous Nation."
That's a long explanation for a title,
but it is one that really
brings you, I think,
to the core of what I want
to discuss in this book
about what states relatively intact
and what changes over time.
So the book is three parts to it.
My students, when I was writing it,
like to joke that the
first part deals with about
500 years of Sino-Korean relations.
And the second part deals
with maybe 70, 80 years
of Sino-Korean relations.
And the third part deals
with the last three weeks
of Sino-Korean relations.
It's not quite as bad as that,
but the first part is very
much about the relationship
between two empires based in
China, the Ming and the Ching,
and the Joseon State that both
of them had to interact with,
going up to the late 19th century.
The second part, which I
call the internationalization
of East Asia, China, Korea, and the world
goes from the 1860s, 1870s, up to 1992.
And then the third one
deals with the period
much more recently and
particularly the future
of Sino-Korean relations
in the 21st century.
So that is how the book is constructed.
Let me talk just very
briefly about each of these
three parts before I pass the
floor over to Professor Kim,
and then perhaps you can talk about
some of these afterwards.
So I said that both Ming
and Joseon were created
in a very similar time period
at the end of the 14th century,
very much under the influence
of the same points of ideas
about state and the
construction of society,
the reconstruction of society
at the end of the 14th century.
In both cases, as historians have shown,
you could talk about a
Neo-Confucian revolution.
It's particularly striking
in the Joseon project,
because of the way the regime
in spite of its own institutes
and difficulties with getting established,
as many of you will know about,
insisted on the Neo-Confucian framework
as being the foundation of the state
in a very direct, rather concrete way.
The Ming, which by the
way, as many of you know,
had the same problems
with getting the empire,
the dynasty established,
also used forms of Neo-Confucian thinking
in order to establish that state.
I don't have time to
go into the differences
between the two.
There were significant differences.
But there were also
significant similarities.
And one of the trends that I follow then
for the 15th and the
16th century especially,
is how various ideas and
concepts on the Korean
and on the Chinese side
mutually strengthen,
reinforce each other during
a long-term conversation
among your Neo-Confucian
scholars that go on
during those two centuries,
or at least up to the middle
part of the 16th century.
I find that hugely interesting,
because it is one of
those cases where you find
that there is a culture.
And it's right to call
this a culture, I think.
Even though it's more limited
than many other forms
of culture that we know.
Where you have people from
very different backgrounds
speaking different languages,
but of course expressing themselves
in written form in similar terms.
Exchanging ideas about how you can build
and just write your state.
And also crucially about
how the relationship
between the two should work.
And that is where the issue that I deal
with more than anything else
in the first chapter really comes too,
because it is one thing to
proclaim Confucian righteousness.
It's another thing to
try to implement this
in the relationship between states.
And that's of course something
that the Sino- Korean
relationship has always
had trouble with defining.
So what I find is that in
spite of this flourishing world
of exchange of ideas, and
for that matter also of goods
that existed between China and Korea,
the Joseon insistence on being linked
but outside the empire,
is perhaps the core value
that regulates the
relationship between the two.
And this is important, because
the main in other forms,
as many of you will know,
and of course the Ching
even more than followed it,
were expansionist states, right?
It wasn't given from the beginning,
particularly with this
definition of a common culture,
that the Joseon state would
necessarily stay outside
of these expanding empires,
and particularly through for the Ching.
So in addition to the principles
that both of them based themselves on,
there also had to be a
lot of practical thinking
about how this relationship
should actually work,
and how it should be expressed.
Because within the
Neo-Confucian framework,
again, as many of you will know,
how you express things is
of incredible significance
in terms of how you should
understand the reality
that you live in terms of consent.
So the question I asked
towards the end of that chapter
is how it was possible
for a much weaker state
as Joseon definitely was
to keep its independence?
And I deliberately used the
modern term independence.
When confronted with
an empire with empires,
that were expansionist and
inclusionists in many ways.
And my answer to that
question is manifold, right?
One, which I think is truly important,
is through the principle
of always knowing more
about the empire than the
empire knows about you.
That could be a fancy
name for intelligence,
and it is to some extent,
though it was much
wider than intelligence.
So the tribute missions
that took place to China,
to the Ming, then to the Ching afterwards,
were also fantastic opportunities
for gathering information
about the empire and
the empire's intentions.
And I would go as far as saying
that if it weren't for that,
then Joseon would have
been much more exposed
with regard to China than
what was the case in reality,
particularly during the
transition from Ming to Ching,
which, and I don't have
time to go into that today,
but also of course, highly problematic
from a Korean point of view.
So knowing more about the empire
than the empire knows about you
is a very important part of it.
The other part is of course
to show as Joseon scholars
and the Joseon state showed increasingly
as you get into the 17th and 18th century,
that you can be better
practitioners of Confucianism,
Neo-Confucianism, than
what even the empire can.
This is a remarkable time
period when we think about it
in ideological terms,
in the relationship between
the Ching and the Joseon.
How was it possible for the Joseon kings
to get away after the big changeover,
and after have it confronted and lost
against the Ching armies
in the early 17th century.
Not just to keep its own independence,
but keep on venerating
long dead Ming emperors
who are of course the sworn
enemies of the Ching Dynasty
that was knowing case in
China, and get away with it.
And the insistence that
what Confucian scholars
and the Confucian court,
Joseon did in this context,
was to practice righteousness with regard
to the emperors that had gone before,
and that had had a relationship to Korea.
I call it in the book
of Azrael relationship.
It's hard to find an English term
that actually works for this.
Because the important
thing for me is that Korea
is linked to the empire,
but outside of it.
So whatever way you wanna express.
They were allowed to go on doing that,
because of that shared inheritance
that even the Ching respected.
And that level of even
rather contrary Sinocentrism
is of course then what gets
into trouble increasingly
towards the end of the 19th century
when the Ching itself is receded.
It's not that the Joseon elite
are particularly fond of
the Ching, they are not.
But living in a world
where the Chinese empire,
a Chinese empire that Korea
has so long been linked
to in one form or another,
offers both enormous challenges,
maybe first and foremost in
the relationship to Japan,
but also enormous
opportunities for rethinking
what kind of state formation
that a truly independent
career should have.
Now, that's what then defines
the second chapter of the book.
Because it is in many ways an
enforced internationalization
on East Asian that takes
place during this period.
Enforced first and foremost,
because of Japanese aggression,
against Korean for that
matter, against China as well.
But also because other
countries get into the mix
in terms of defining the framework.
It's so far removed from what you find
in the early 19th century.
Never mind the 17th and the 18th century.
My verdict in the book is that
in spite of being occupied,
of being colonized, losing
its independence to Japan,
Korea, and being, you know,
suffering the consequences of that,
almost immediately in Korea.
You have this transition over to new forms
of thinking about nation and nationalism
coming out of the late 19th century.
One could almost go as far as saying that
part of the tragedy of
Korea in the 20th century
was that just as these new concept
of what Korea consisted came of age,
the country was occupied by Japan.
So these forms of nationalism
all had to grow up in exile.
And we know what happens to nationalisms
that grow up in exile.
They get hypercharged,
and they get absolutely convinced
that the only version of
a future for a country
is the version that their particular brand
of concept of nation
or nationalism consist.
So by saying that, I'm
not saying the same thing
as some historians have been saying,
including some American historians.
That the division, the origins
of the division of Korea
should be sought in
those early divergences
of Korean nationalism.
I don't think that is enough of itself
as a cause and effect.
I mean, the division of Korea
came out of the Second
World War, and the Cold War,
and the division of the
two occupation cells,
without any doubt.
But what it did was that it
fueled the concepts of nation
and national aims that then took root
both in the south and in the north.
It shaped and formed them in ways
that are really, really significant.
So that is then leads up then
to the third and final part
of the book, where I
talk about the relations
between China and the
two Korean states today.
I'm not gonna go into
that too deeply here,
you can read the book, now also in Korean.
But I'm basically saying
that much of the current
Chinese policy towards
the two Korean states
is based on some of those
principles and ideas
that come out of the past,
but in a new kind of format.
And that new kind of format
is definitely based on China's own rights,
the PLC's own rights, as an economic power
over the past generation.
Some ideas in that right
have come from Korea,
just as some ideas about the organization
of Confucian society in the Ming
in the 16th century came from Korea.
But there are also an increasing,
and to me worrisome level,
within the PLC of developing a form
of Chinese nationalism
that projects two Korea,
to both Koreas and to other
countries in the region,
a new form of Sinocentrism
that go beyond what you saw
even during the Ming and
probably also the Ching empire.
It is a form of putting
China at the center
that asks not for linkages,
and that form of intellectual
cultural inclusion.
Even under pressure has happened
in the case of the Ching.
But in diplomatic and strategic terms,
and will punish countries at
the borders that do not profess
to the same understanding
of that centrality,
that central role of China
as the current PLC leaders professed.
That worries me.
It doesn't.
Not because of the way some of
our American colleagues are saying,
"Oh, this is bringing China
back to the way it was
during the great dynasties."
It's not doing that.
It is presenting us with a
completely new kind of problem
in terms of how China's fantastic
race, an admirable race,
will influence the smaller
countries that surround it,
whether that will be a cooperative form,
or authoritarian, and
forced form of cooperation
between China and these countries.
So there, that's where I
leave it in terms of the book.
It's a very brief book, so
you might be able to read it
in a couple of afternoons if
you have an interest in it.
I don't write many brief books.
So if you want to read
a brief book of mine,
this might be a good place to stop.
So that is what I had to say.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Hwansoo] Okay now, Professor Youn.
- Yes, sir.
Okay, thank you.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Myung Chul Youn.
Yes, okay.
I'm a professor and a poet.
And sometimes I say too, I'm an explorer.
Sometimes, sometimes, okay.
(speaking in Korean)
Goguryeo Kingdom is very
important in Korean histories,
and everything, and
especially maritime history
of East Asian.
This is my main study.
(speaking in Korean)
(Juhn speaking in Korean)
- Okay, I'm sorry. (laughs)
(speaking in Korean)
(Juhn speaking in Korean)
- The books are written me.
Today is very important to me,
to Koreans, to Americans, and the world.
This is a reason, it is my idea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Right now, a lot
of people are interested
in East Asia, especially
Korea's place within East Asia.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] But a lot of
people have misperceptions
and misconceptions about
East Asia and Korea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] First, there's this
idea that Korea is an appendage
or connected branch of
Chinese history in thought.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] There's also this
idea that Korea's history
and culture is limited to what happened
in the Korean Peninsula.
- Yes, okay.
Yes, the hermit kingdom and
the land of the morning calm.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Those expressions,
hermit kingdom and the
land of the morning calm
are expressions that appeared
in the late 19th century
and were often used by
foreigners to refer to Korea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And that's stuck,
and that's how people continue
to refer to Korea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And there is the misperception
that Korea has continued to
be a nation that was oppressed
by either China or Japan.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And these two
kingdoms in the past,
Goguryeo and Balhae, are often understood
just simply as parts of Chinese history.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And these claims
have been advanced by scholars
in China recently.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And there is the
claim that has been advanced
that ancient Korea was dominated by Japan.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] I'm a historian,
I work with facts,
and I believe that these
claims are not based on facts.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] We need to
look at Korean history.
So let's start with this map.
This is a map of Eurasia.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] In my view,
there are six major paths
of connections that connected Eurasia.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The most important are the three
that he just pointed out, the
steppe road, the silk road,
and the maritime trade route
road on the bottom left.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And it's very
important to understand
these geographic developments,
to understand Korea properly.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Koreans use
the word the Han people.
- Han people for the nation.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And this is very
different from the way the word
nation is used by other countries.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] I'll explain
what that means next time.
- Friday.
- Okay, Friday.
Yes, Friday. (laughs)
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So the emergence,
as it says there,
the emergence of the nation's ancestor,
or the origins of the Korean ethnic group,
dates back to 15 to 12 century BCE.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] There wasn't a
complete radical displacement
of the people in the Korean Peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So a lot of
cultures and people came in,
but it blended with the existing
local cultures and traditions.
because the local cultures
and traditions were so strong.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] There were two occasions
when Korea was conquered.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] But that didn't result
in the complete transformation
of the Korean people.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And this is a
unique characteristic
that makes it very different
from the Mongols, Turks,
and others.
- Okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So he, Professor
Youn, calls Korea a living
in a cultural and also
a historical community.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And because these are so strong,
Koreans have this sense, a
strong sense of community.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] A lot of people
are interested in the issue
of how Koreans emerge,
or where Koreans emerge.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Professor Youn's theory
is that eight route for use
for people to migrate
into the Korean Peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So the three routes
that were mentioned earlier
through the Baikal area, and
also through the Silk Road,
and the maritime route were
the three most important routes
to which people entered the peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So early Koreans
were influenced very heavily
by northern peoples,
especially those who
speak the Altaic language.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] But there was also a
culture that was transmitted
via India and Southeast Asia into Korea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So in Professor Youn's view,
the best way to understand
the emergence of Korea
is to understand as the foundation,
the entrance of people
through the northern route,
but also supplemented and grown
through the entry of people
through the maritime southern route.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The theory that
the native people of Korea
originated from the Korean Peninsula,
this is a theory that is
popular in North Korea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] I'll provide
an alternative theory.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] I divide East Asian civilizations
into these three separate civilizations.
- Chinese civilization, one.
And the second, northern civilization,
and the eastern civilization.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Divide into three
civilization, (laughs)
Chinese, northern, and eastern.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So in the eastern
civilization he includes
the Japanese archipelago, Korea,
and of course, the lands
of Manchuria as well.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] In a more narrow sense,
we can think about East Asia this way.
(speaking in Korean)
- Professor Youn to understand East Asia
created a new model,
and called it the East
Asian Mediterranean Sea.
(speaking in Korean)
- And since 20 years ago,
since he developed it,
this theory has been in wide use
in other parts of the world as well.
(speaking in Korean)
- The Mediterranean Sea,
as you can see here,
connects various points on this map,
and connects various
regions and countries today
into one region.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So his theory is
different from previous theories.
In that, he places Korea at
the core of the geopolitics
of the East Asian Mediterranean Sea.
He puts Korea as the
hub of the geoeconomics
of the Mediterranean Sea.
He also puts Korea in
the interchange point
of the geo culture of the
East Asia Mediterranean Sea.
And last but not least,
an expression that he coined himself,
he puts Korea at the
heart of the geo mentalogy
of the East Asian Mediterranean Sea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] But this does not
apply to the Joseon period.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a map that was created
in the Joseon period.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So this, what you see
here is a conception of Korea
that is no more than a thousand years old.
And prior to that, the Korean
conception of territory
was much larger, and it
encompassed everything
from areas up in Manchuria
down to the Japanese islands.
- Yeah.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] He's just gonna skip the period,
because it's well known.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So Gojoseon is
the country or kingdom
that Koreans considered to
be the very first kingdom,
Korean kingdom to have ever existed.
But Professor Youn
actually profess to call it
not all Joseon, which is
the literal translation
of the word Gojoseon,
but rather Proto-Joseon.
- Okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is my book on Proto-Joseon.
- Okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Gojoseon's
territory roughly coincides
with what is today Liaodong
Peninsula, the Middle Manchuria,
and also middle to north
regions of the Korean Peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] I use these
four things as evidence
to claim that that was the
territories of Proto-Joseon.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] There are lot of dolmens,
these are huge stone structures
that were constructed everywhere.
Apparently, there's over 40,000 of these.
I didn't know that.
Currently in existence.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a Gojoseon
or Proto-Joseon dolmen
that currently exists in
Southern Liaodong Peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] That's him. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So you can see how big it is.
- Okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a dolmen
Pyongyang in North Korea today.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] There are a lot of these.
- [Juhn] This is in North Jeolla province
in South Korea today.
- Yes.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is in South
Jeolla province in South Korea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] In just that Jeolla region alone,
there are over 20,000 dolmens.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is in North
Gyeongsang province,
which is in the southeastern
corner of the Korean Peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] But the shape of the
dolmens in the north and south
of the Korean Peninsula are different.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] It's not a
fundamental difference,
but rather a difference in style.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a typical sword
from the Proto-Joseon period.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Pretty, isn't it? (laughs)
- Yes, sir.
(speaking in Korean)
One, two, three.
- [Juhn] So he finds a logic in this,
and he believes that it's can
be divided into three parts.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] He believes
that this wasn't actually
meant to be used as a weapon,
but rather as a ritual to implement.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] All right.
- [Juhn] So the image on the left
is from Liaodong Peninsula,
and the image on the
right is from the Liaoxi.
Two opposite directions of the same area.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And this is an
example of that blade
that was found in Japan.
(speaking in Korean)
(audience laughing)
- [Juhn] So that's drawing
of the thing that you see
on the right there, it
was done by his wife.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The husband
and wife work together
to reconstruct Korea's past.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Nationalists. (laughs)
Patriot, sorry, patriot.
(audience laughing)
That's a lot of words, sorry. (laughs)
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So these are bronze mirrors,
and he believes that the
bronze mirrors in China,
and the ones that you found
in the northern steppes,
and also the bronze mirrors
found in the Korean Peninsula
are all different in style.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So some bronze mirrors
around the third century
of the common era from
China, can be found in Japan,
but there are a lot
more that actually came
from the Korean Peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Can you see the words?
(Juhn speaking in Korean language)
(speaking in Korean)
- One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, 100.
- So there are
13,000 lines, and then it's some.
- Yes.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And this is between the lines
is what you see up there.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And he believes
that this is evidence
of incredible technology.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The ability or the capacity
to create bronze mirrors and bronze swords
means that they were at the
top of the technological game.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] He wants to, once
again, reemphasize the fact that
bronze mirrors produced in China,
and the bronze mirrors produced
in Korea are very different.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Now that you've
heard what I had to say,
you can see the significance
of what you see here on this map, right?
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So when we go beyond the narrow
understanding of nation, and
we understand it culturally,
you can see that Korea
encompasses a territory
that is much bigger than
the way it's imagined today.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So in the interest of time,
he's gonna skip over the
fact that there are dolmens
that are found in other areas
that are currently China today.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So around the turn
of the millennium in Korea,
what you see is the
rise of three kingdoms,
Goguryeo, Baekje, and Silla.
- Okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The first is
Goguryeo, as you see here.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The origins of
this particular kingdom
is believed to be the middle
part of the Yalu river
and also middle Manchuria.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So we should
take note of the fact that
the origins of Proto-Joseon
and also Goguryeo
lie outside of the Korean Peninsula,
and what is today Manchuria.
- This is very important.
Okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The founder of the
kingdom is named Jumong,
and he considered himself,
or called himself,
the son of heaven.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And he believes
that the heaven here
does not refer to the heaven
used in the old Jo text,
or the Confucian classics,
but rather to the heaven
that is worshiped up
by the northern steppe
people, like the Mongols.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And so he
believes that the Goguryeo
inherited much from Proto-Joseon,
and also from the northern steppe people.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So this is a
painting of the father
of the founder of Goguryeo,
and he's considered to be God in heaven.
And this is a painting
that's currently housed
in North Korea today near
what they believe to be,
or in the shrine where they
believe to be his tomb.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] He used the name of that God
for the wrath that he took himself
to go from an island in Korea
all the way over to Japan,
just to show you that the
7,000 years of maritime trade
and exchange did indeed
happen, and could happen.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] He's crossed from
Jiujiang in China over to Korea
three times already.
- Yeah.
(speaking in Korean)
(Juhn speaking in Korean)
- So the travel from China to an island
called Heuksando was 17 days.
And he also took a raft to travel
all the way over to Japan
as well, which took,
I think he said 43 days out
of which 10 were actually
he spent in sail.
(speaking in Korean)
- I look weak, but trust me, I'm not.
(audience laughing)
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So he wants to make sure that,
he makes it very clear that
what you're actually seeing here
is not necessarily a concept of territory,
but rather area of influence.
And this area of influence was real,
and it reached, as you can
see, far really up north
into territories that are still
subjects of controversy today,
especially among scholars
of China and Japan.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And he reconstruct
this area of influence
using archeological and textual evidence.
So he doesn't think that
there's really any room
for different interpretations.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So at the height
of Goguryeo's history,
China was in disarray
fighting amongst each other
and kingdoms like Goguryeo,
and other northern tribes
took advantage of this fact
to increase their influence in that area.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] I'll tell you a fun story.
- [Juhn] So the fun story is
the folks that you see here,
the Rouran, I think, they
traveled far out west,
and they reached all the way over to Italy
where they settled.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Goguryeo was able to
take advantage of the split
of China in Northern Wei
and the Southern Song,
and engaged in long distance trade.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And the person
who facilitated all this
is known to be King Gwanggaeto,
who still you see here.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The stele is 6.39 meters tall,
and it contains over 1,700 words.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] What he wants to emphasize
is not necessarily the size
or the ambitions of the king,
but rather the place of Korea
within the larger geopolitical
system on that period.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And what he
wants to emphasize is that
the place of Goguryeo in this
larger geopolitical system
was a peaceful one.
And that's what they aspired,
and that was a worldview at the time.
(speaking in Korean)
- And the beauty, and the
logic, and the meaning.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So he wrote
something about this stele,
and the title contains those
words that you just heard,
beauty, logic, that's all.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Guys, that's the king's tomb.
(Youn speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And it's a pyramid.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And this is what
that pyramid looks like.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Tombs likes like this,
they're over 12 in Manchuria,
but the only one that currently remains
is this one that you see here.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] On Friday,
he'll delve deeper into the philosophical
meanings of that too.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So please come Friday.
- [Juhn] So in year 427,
Goguryeo moved its capital
to what is today North
Korea, to its new palace,
the Anhak Palace.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And that's the
castle from that area.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is from a mural
from the fifth and sixth century CE.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And this is a depiction
of a warrior of an army
that boasted one of the most
powerful armies at the time.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So this predicts the Turkish
depictions of the warriors
by about 100 years.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And on Friday, I'll talk about
the function of these warriors.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Let's now talk about
Baekje, the other kingdom.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Baekje was established
by people who fled from Goguryeo.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And at the
beginning for that reason,
they frequently had
skirmishes with Goguryeo,
but they later started to have wars
with their neighbor in the south Silla.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And around fourth century CE,
they began to expand
their areas of influence
to the Japanese archipelago.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is Baekje's first capital.
And the river that you see
there is the famous Han River,
which splits the capital Seoul.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] You can see the outlines
of the original wall of the capitol,
and you can see that it's
located right by the river,
which means that this
was a maritime kingdom.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] A lot of these
ancient cities from this period
are maritime cities,
and they were designed
to take advantage of maritime.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] That's history.
- [Juhn] So this is a castle
that was used by Goguryeo
as their military for.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And that's why you
see around the Han River
Baekje period pyramids that
look a lot like the pyramids
from Goguryeo.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So there are
a lot of these pyramids
from the Goguryeo in Manchuria.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] He went there 70 times.
- Yes, okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The last kingdom
to emerge is Silla,
the founder is known to be
a man named Hyeokgeose Khan.
(speaking in Korean)
- Okay.
- [Juhn] The word Kan in this context
refers the ruler or the nation.
- Genghis Khan, no.
Genghis Khan is the correct.
Genghis Khan.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And that word Khan
comes from Altaic languages,
and is shared among people who
want to refer to the ruler.
To refer to the ruler.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So the map of
Goguryeo is a little off,
it should be a bit lower at the top there,
but what you're seeing here is Silla
at the height of its power.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So Koreans tend to,
or prefer to see Goguryeo
as being much larger than it actually was.
But the territories that
Goguryeo dispatch officials,
and controlled indirectly
was a much smaller area.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] He highlighted
this fact in red here,
because he wants to
emphasize the fact that
around the fifth to the sixth century,
there seemed to be culturally a connection
between Silla and the Xiongnu up north.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a very
complicated question.
- Yes.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So these are tomb from Silla
when you excavate them,
what you find are remnants
of cultural patterns that you can connect
with the northern people like the Xiongnu.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] That's the Silla
palace, reconstruction of Anapji.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a
golden crown from Silla.
Silla is hands down, the most
prolific producer of these,
of golden crowns.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] It's a fact.
- Yes.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So that crown that
you see there on the right
is from Kazakhstan, and
there are a lot of people
who draw connections.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And on Friday, he's
gonna show you all the crowns.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So there's another kingdom,
or federation known as
Gaya, and he believes that
these are maritime city states, or polis.
These are really smallest
city states that came together
as a federation, and that's history.
- Oh, sorry.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And those are the
different colors represent
the different city states
known as the six Gaya.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So the Gaya cultural group,
they actually began at the southern tip
of the Korean Peninsula,
but they began to expand their territories
and areas of influence
into Japanese islands.
And more Gaya influence began
to grow as a consequence
deeper in the middle of the peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So archeological
evidence points to movement
of Gaya folk into the Japanese islands
around the fourth century BCE.
But textual material from
Japan points to that happening
sometime around the
turn of the millennium.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] The closest place
to get to Japan from Korea
is the city of Busan,
which is where was under
controlled by Gaya.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And it's an area where you find
a lot of Gaya period.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And that's a cultural artifact
that was unearthed near Busan.
And you can see that it's the remains of
(speaking in Korean).
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And obviously,
it was influenced heavily
by Goguryeo culture
- Okay.
- up north.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] A lot of people don't
understand Korean history,
but what they really
don't understand is that
Korea was heavily
engaged in maritime trade
and interaction with other areas.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a book
maritime history in Korea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] It's been
translated to Vietnamese.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] They tried to
translate it to Chinese,
but they didn't get the
permissions to do so.
- Yeah.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So it was published
in Chinese but in Korea.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] He really wants this book
to be translated into
Japanese and English as well.
- Yes.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a depiction
of the maritime trade routes
of Goguryeo.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And these are the
maritime trade routes of Baekje.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So the Northern
Wei was established
by Xianbei people from up north.
And those who fled the
incursion of the Northern Wei,
they established the
kingdoms out in the south,
the Song, the Southern Qi,
the Liang, and the Jin.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And the Silla folk
also traveled across the street
to the Japanese islands through
these maritime trade routes.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] We use archeological artifacts,
and also Japanese records like
the Kojiki and Nihon Shoki
to reconstruct these trades.
- Okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And that's the
path of influence of Gaya.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And I explained
all of this in my book
on ancient Japan.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a very important bed.
This is an international
war that takes place
during this period at the
end of the sixth century.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So the system of the
three countries, China, Korea,
and Japan emerges in the wake
of this international war.
And this was really
the consequence of Tang
emerging victorious in this war.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And it's a war
that lasted over 70 years.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And those are the
reasons behind the war.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So it's a war
between China and Goguryeo,
but in direct or indirect
ways, everybody else,
the surrounding states
and policies were involved
in this international war as well.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And this is what that
war basically looked like.
(Youn speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And that's how many soldiers
were involved in the war between Sui
that is the predecessor to
the Tang Dynasty and Goguryeo.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So Sui Dynasty
loses that war with Goguryeo,
and collapses in 40 years.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Tang's Taizong invades
with a troop of 100,000
with 500 ships, and so on,
but they actually lose that battle.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And these are
again all based on facts.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So this is the
third and last word,
the first again was
between Sui and Goguryeo.
Second, Tang and Goguryeo.
And the third is the
alliance that was formed
between Tang, China, and Silla,
which eventually results in
the collapse of Goguryeo.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So Baekje is
gonna collapse as well.
Those red dots that you saw
on the Japanese islands,
those were force established
by the Baekje immigrants.
And you can see from this
how the intimate relationship
between the Baekje
immigrants and Japanese.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And the significance
of this event is that
it's roughly around this
time that we begin to see
the rise of what we call Japan today.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And the name Nihon
Koni, I suppose, in Japanese,
emerges during this period.
And you can see the significance of these-
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] All in the five minutes.
- [Juhn] So Balhae is a
successor state to Goguryeo,
and this is advanced in old
Chinese dynastic histories.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And in the Shoku
Nihongi Japanese history,
it states clearly that the Balhae king
was attempting to recover
Goguryeo's old territory,
hence the Appalachian successor's state.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And in wooden tablets
and also ceramic dishes
found in Japan, they refer
to the envoys from Balhae
as actually envoys or diplomats
sent to, or from Goguryeo.
So you can see that Balhae and Goguryeo
had a very close relationship.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And from the fact that
Balhae use its own era names
shows you how independent they were.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Joseon, for example,
cannot use its own era names.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Because it
was under the influence
of Chinese culture.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Well, Goguryeo
and Balhae were different
in this regard.
- Yeah.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And there are
a lot of records of them
identifying themselves as the descendants
from the God of heaven.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] So this reconstructions
of the territories
of Balhae are based on
archeological evidence,
and the northeastern territories,
the archeological evidence
was done of course by-
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is not
my field of expertise,
so I've relied on the expertise of others.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] This is a depiction
done by the Chinese
of the fort of the palace of Balhae.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And that's the
front gate of that palace.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And this is my last slide.
- [Juhn] He calls Balhae,
the Vikings of Asia.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And in the 220 years,
they sent more than 34 envoys.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And 1,100 immigrants
had crossed the strait,
but then they were forced to return.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] I've traveled this
sea, myself, many times,
on a yacht, on a raft. (laughs)
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And I took a boat all the way up
to the northern seas.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] For 90 days.
- [Juhn] But that sea that you see there
is a very difficult sea to navigate.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Especially in the winter,
it's very difficult to cross.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] But because the Balhae people
had to cross the ocean,
they had to rely on the
northeasterly winds.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] And that's why I
call them the Vikings of Asia.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] There may be scholars of Japan
and Japanese students here.
(speaking in Korean)
- [Juhn] Japanese are very
proud of their maritime history.
A lot of this was reconstructed
using Japanese sources
on the subject.
(speaking in Korean)
- Finally, the time is arrived
that you were all waiting for.
This is the end of the lecture,
thank you all very much.
(audience applauding)
- So why don't we give an
opportunity to our speakers
to ask questions of each other.
So Professor Westad, do
you have any question
for Professor Youn?
- Actually, I find the
exposition fascinating
in terms of looking at the various stages
of the development of for me and his.
And I know that your own
expertise is connected earlier.
(speaking in Korean)
- So I had many questions.
One question I had was
about the composition
of the original inhabitants
of this larger Korean area
that you outlined.
(speaking in Korean)
- So is there any recent genetic research
that would show some of the connections
between the original
inhabitants in these areas
and neighboring groups?
Because it's always a
big question in terms of
how these people have traveled
in terms of settlement.
- Right.
- But also sometimes with
a little bit of luck,
genetic research, DNA research,
can tell us something about
how cultures travel between they took.
(speaking in Korean)
- Okay.
- So scholars believe that
the inhabitants of the Korean Peninsula
in terms of their genetic
makeup and whatnot,
had already been established
pretty much by the,
somewhere between the fifth
to the seventh century CE.
(speaking in Korean)
- So based on textual records,
we know that there was connections
between Tungusic and the Mongoloid people
up in the northern steppes with people
who will come to inhabit
the Korean Peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- So he, okay, this is tough. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
So he distinguishes between a core group
and then a periphery group.
And the periphery group will actually
establish conquest dynasties
in what are territories
in China today.
- Yes.
(speaking in Korean)
- So there is some DNA evidence to suggest
that the vast majority
came from the north.
There is some DNA evidence to suggest
that there was an immigration
from the south as well.
But Professor Youn himself
does not really think that
to understand the
formation of the historical
cultural community during this period
that DNA is very important.
(speaking in Korean)
- And it really depends
on where you collect
the DNA evidence.
- Yes.
- So, that's why
he doesn't give it too much credits.
(speaking in Korean)
- So the big difference
between the Chinese today
and Koreans is that the
Koreans are connected,
or descendants of the northern Mongoloids.
(speaking in Korean)
- So there are the northern Mongoloids
and the southern Mongoloids.
(speaking in Korean)
- So Koreans are mainly descendants
of the northern Mongoloids
who belong to the Altaic
linguistics people.
(speaking in Korean)
- There are more recent research
has come to criticize or deny the
Altaic language group theory,
but there's plenty of
evidence to suggest otherwise.
(speaking in Korean)
- And he believes that in our
culture, our blood, and so on.
There are still-
- Like language and culture.
- Right, and language.
There are still strong traces
of the northern steppe culture
in history.
- I had just one more question if I may.
I was fascinated by this
concept of the eastern,
or the Eastern Asian Mediterranean.
- Okay.
- So this idea about how influence spread,
and how goods were
exchanged in terms of this.
And I'm like, you fascinated by the sea.
Not surprising since I come from no one.
(audience laughing)
(speaking in Korean)
- So I was wondering in terms of
the kind of maritime vessels,
the ships that we think
were being used for
these kinds of exchanges,
were these different kinds of ships?
Do we know anything about that at all?
And was ship building technology.
Because there must have
been a lot of ships
going in different direction there.
Was that influenced
across the various areas,
or are there very different kinds of ships
that contributed to this?
(speaking in Korean)
- If you know anything about that.
- No, no.
(speaking in Korean)
- So he's convinced that the ship building
and the maritime technology,
China was at the top.
But unfortunately, we don't have records
from Korea or Japan to say more about it.
(speaking in Korean)
- So there's some
evidence that you can find
from the Yayu in Kofun period in Japan,
where you look at the murals,
and you can see images of ships,
and we can use those to sort of guess
what the ships actually look like.
(speaking in Korean)
- So Professor Youn says that
the ships used in the eastern
and the western seas were very different,
and the ones used in the eastern sea,
the one that connected
what is Russia today
created in Japan, were
probably much closer in design
to the Viking ships.
(speaking in Korean)
- And the sails themselves
have to be square.
(speaking in Korean)
- And he believes that
this design had to be used,
because of the size of the waves,
- Yes.
- and the need
to rely on the north,
east, and west.
- And also distance.
I mean the distance.
- And the distance, yes.
(speaking in Korean)
- So Chinese sources,
they tell you exactly how
the ships were designed.
So we have far more
details about that from.
(speaking in Korean)
- And so he doesn't
deny the sophistication
of Chinese ship building technology.
- Okay, since we don't have much time,
why don't just jump into
just sharing with you,
maybe two or three
questions from the audience.
The most kind of obvious and funny one.
- Okay.
- Why did you feel so
ambitious to cross the waters
(audience laughing)
between Korea and Japan
to understand the experience yourself?
(speaking in Korean)
- He believes that history
is based on action.
(speaking in Korean)
- You can't understand their
happiness, their sorrow,
their pain, or anything
unless you experience it for yourself.
(speaking in Korean)
- You have to experience it for yourself
to just even get a glimpse
of what the experiences
back in the day were like.
(speaking in Korean)
- And he believes that there's
a meaning of existence,
not only to human beings,
to every single thing.
(speaking in Korean)
- And he believes that
that was the way of thought
in the worldview of the
ancient Korean people as well.
(speaking in Korean)
- Okay, this question.
I thought my handwriting was really bad,
but wow,
(audience laughing)
that's kinda archeological project.
(speaking in Korean)
- You mentioned several
cultural connections
between ancient Korean
people and Altaic peoples.
As far as I know, the Altaic hypothesis
positing relationship
between Japanese, Korean,
and various inner Asian
languages has been,
finally I got the languages,
(audience laughing)
has been largely disproven
by American and European linguists.
- Okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- Okay, I know.
Okay, I know.
- So what does the category
Altaic mean to you?
And does Korean language on
culture fall under the category,
or is it separate but related to it?
(speaking in Korean)
- I mean history.
- So my opinion is very different
from that of a linguist.
(speaking in Korean)
- So he is well aware of the fact
that the Altaic language family theory
is under attack and has been criticized.
(speaking in Korean)
- But he doesn't think that you can deny
that there was an Altaic
linguistic cultural sphere.
(speaking in Korean)
- And there is strong
evidence of influence
of all the northern steppes
in the Korean Peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- So he'll talk about the
traces of these influence
of the northern steppes
in more detail on Friday.
(speaking in Korean)
- So he understands that linguists
now deny the Altaic cultural sphere
and linguistic sphere
theory, but as a historian,
he believes that such a sphere did exist,
and that it is very
useful in understanding
the cultural interactions
between the northern steppes
in the Korean Peninsula.
(speaking in Korean)
- Sorry.
(Hwansoo speaking in Korean)
- Okay, yeah.
(speaking in Korean)
- So most people place
- Sorry.
- the center of the Altaic cultural sphere
in the Altaic mountain range,
but he believes that it
should be placed further west
above Uzbekistan and the grasslands there,
and that in moves-
(speaking in Korean)
- Ukraine, Ukraine.
- Ukraine, very important. (laughs)
(speaking in Korean)
- I'm sorry.
- [Hwansoo] So we have
two remaining questions.
The following question you can
just answer yes or no, okay?
- Okay, I'm sorry.
- Was the founder of
Gojoseon, Proto-Joseon,
- Yes.
- ever honored in the same
way that Gija or Tangun were?
(speaking in Korean)
- The Korean people, (speaking
in Korean)?
- No.
- No?
Okay.
(speaking in Korean)
- Oh, okay, I'm sorry.
- So, then answer the question directly,
but he says that the word Joseon appears
in very early Chinese sources.
It also appears in the
13th century Korean source.
This is a very important
source known as Samguk Yusa.
And there's clear evidence of
the fact that successor states
clearly look to the Joseon
as the state that they were succeeding.
And so he believes that there
is that connection there.
(speaking in Korean)
- So scholars distinguish
between Tangun Joseon,
Gija Joseon, and Wiman Joseon,
but this is something that scholars do,
but not something that really exists in.
(speaking in Korean)
- It's a very difficult question.
- Yes.
(speaking in Korean)
- So he finds it very difficult himself
to actually answer the question
of Gija and Wiman Joseon.
(speaking in Korean)
- But I do actually advance
my own personal views
as historian.
(speaking in Korean)
- So as a scholar, he denies
the theory of Gija Joseon,
but he does accept Wiman Joseon
as part of Korean history.
- Okay, the time is up.
I'm the person of keeping
the promise. (laughs)
So those of you who wrote questions,
and haven't heard the answer,
you can actually come forward
and ask him in person.
But thank you again,
Professor Westad, for coming,
(audience applauding)
and it's a wonderful talk.
And thank you, Professor Youn.
This Friday at 12,
we're gonna have the
second part of the talk
with Korean food, okay?
So please come. (laughs)
Thank you so much, you guys.
Thank you, have a wonderful evening.
(bright music)